I saw you right after Michelle passed
away and and and and I was wondering
today you know I just want to ask you
how are you doing like on a human level
what's your life like right now you are
you are you holding up okay I mean I'm
I'm here I you know I'm I'm but it's
like I'm a it's feels were saying I'm a
widower I'm a widower and and like if I
put it in really basic terms I'm like
every bad 80s sitcom where they there's
a dad raising a kid by himself and the
mom is somehow except my 80s sitcom
sucks
there's no punchlines it's just there's
a lot of insomnia there's a lot of me
eating Cheetos for dinner and I'm
waiting for my daughter to turn the
camera go no wonder I'm in therapy like
good but that's not gonna there's that
moments not going to come you're right
you know like she's she's handling it
way better than I am but you know just
that the Oh God like having and like
what when I the having to tell her that
her mom had passed away as is the worst
thing I will I can't imagine going
through anything like the mass when
death comes to me I'm gonna go like yeah
whatever I've had the worst don't you
know bring you stupid sight in your hood
whatever but she wanted to go back to
school immediately she wanted to go
right back to school in her school like
her school and Michelle's family and my
family basically saved my life those
first three months and and she went
but although going to school and again
she has this great little circle of
friends are all six and seven years old
but six and seven girls they don't have
a filter they just they have questions
they want so you know like literally
three days after Michelle died a little
kid one of her friends came looks like
when Alice's mom died were you sad I was
like I guess I was thank you I don't
know gonna try to us too and then you
also cuz I'm living in LA you get weird
glimpses of her friends what their home
lives might be like like one of her
friends came up and was this was at a
playdate weeks later like is Alice gonna
have a stepmom and I was like I'm not
really thinking about any of that
right now and it said when my mom and
dad stopped living together
I had a stepmom right away very quickly
very quickly and I bet she's teaching
you Russian and I'm gonna bet she's not
teaching your mom Pilates anymore so
there was that kind of things I know
that you've taken your daughter on some
trips to just sort of keep on moving and
keep her is that true
two weeks after Michelle passed away was
Mother's Day mm-hmm and I was like oh
dear God so I talked to her school and I
said I'm gonna take her to Chicago
that's where all of Michelle's families
and they're awesome it's like all of
Alice's cousins and aunts and uncles and
they're just fun cool people and and the
school was like that's a great idea
take her away for that week because that
whole week we'll be talking about
Mother's Day and she's just not you know
we went to Chicago I filled the week
with action and adventure and fun and
cousins and sleepovers and she was and I
got through the week and then on
Mother's Day that Sunday we're gonna
travel all day I'm gonna fill it with
hassle fill it with excitement and keep
her mind off of it and I did it I did it
we were at the airport we're at O'Hare
we're at the gate
we're about to get on the plane we're
gonna watch a movie together on her iPad
I did it I kept it out of her head the
woman that was tearing our tickets at
O'Hare
she was his older polish woman totally
sweet but as we gave her our tickets she
leaned down and said I hear about what
happened to your wife to your mother my
mother died when I was your age I never
got over it and it broke my father he
never get over it
it was horrible you'll be sad for so
long I'm sad every day were literally
like at the gate and I'm like I was so
and now every holiday that comes up like
we got to 4th of July but I'm terrified
that the Polish woman of doom is just
gonna lose
she's gonna go showing up yeah like like
we're gonna go out trick-or-treating at
Halloween's over the little girl when I
see people he's the ghost my mother is
some candy from my country it is made
from pine bark in ink remember like
every now there's I'm haunted like I'm
gonna sit her on Santa's lap at the mall
and take of it it is me it drove him the
loneliness drew drove him to the Far
spectrums of sexuality called beyond
gays
[Laughter]
you